if you had to live
only in the digital world or the
physical world
which would you choose so i i think this
is actually a question
more about what the fidelity of the
digital world would be
versus the physical world i i think this
this type of question this whole
simulation thing actually comes
from papers about 20 30 years ago in in
the philosophical world where people
try to make this thought experiment of
of would you be comfortable
if everything that was happening to you
happened in a simulation
what they were trying to do is they were
intuitively trying to understand
is is there some kind of intuitive um
personal connection we have to something
being the real world
right and then the matrix movie actually
came out of these papers
and then these ideas made its way it
made their way into the public
consciousness
i personally think that if i had the
choice to be in the digital world at the
same fidelity
as the real world with immortality i
would absolutely go with the digital
wait wait wait wait wait how'd you add
the immortality part
that's a well get immortality if you
think about how we would go into the
digital world right our
our our brain patterns would be mapped
onto some kind of uh
probably virtual machine right and that
would mean a multi immortality right
because the virtual machine has no limit
to how long it can be don't you think
there will be like a versioning system
like uh there'll be this is a soft
fork versus hard fork question whether
sergey version 2.0
would be different from sergey version
1.0
there will be an upgrade so that's the
mortality sergey 1.0 will die in the
digital world needs to get
you get like a software update and then
that's it
you know well yeah when people go into
the star trek transporter are they
killed or are they transported
i i don't really know i haven't written
any papers on this i haven't really
thought about it too much there's no
white paper on the transporter
not not at this point so what does
fidelity mean exactly
to you is it like strictly so the
fidelity of the physics world
um the physical world is maybe now
questions of physics
quantum mechanics what is at the at the
bottom of it all
right or do you mean the fidelity of the
actual experience it's just it's just
perception
it's just the human but that's limited
by human cognitive capabilities
it is but i i don't really have anything
else right i think all of these papers
that brought up these questions of a
simulation they were like in
epistemology and metaphysics right
and what they were trying to do i think
was they were trying to put people
through a thought
experiment where they would come out on
the other end and say
the reality of life is really worth
something
and i don't i don't you know ignorance
isn't bliss which is that's
the consistent statement in the matrix
right ignorance is bliss is that that's
what one of the guys says when he's like
you know doing something wrong and
trying to get back into the matrix and
and the question is is ignorance bliss
um and it's like a different version of
that i
i think from a perceptual point of view
if my perceptions
aren't in any way different so fidelity
is very good
it doesn't matter i i don't know right
so if i
that it's if i don't know something it
doesn't really exist and if it doesn't
exist
in in in my perception or my
consciousness then it doesn't exist
period for me at least and then whether
it exists in some
you know more metaphysical um version of
things
i i personally never really got into the
metaphysics stuff because i i could
never really um
i couldn't understand what the point of
it was right
it it um it's one of these things where
i couldn't really get what um
what the what the practical application
of it was and this is this is from those
realm of questions right like
if there was something about the world
but you didn't have a capacity to
perceive it
would it matter to you uh to me it
wouldn't matter
right to me by the way the simulation
thing is a really interesting
engineering question
which is how difficult is it to engineer
a virtual reality a digital world that
is sufficiently
of high fidelity where you would want to
live in it i think that's a really
testable and a fascinating engineering
question because my intuition says like
it's not as difficult as we think
it's not nearly as difficult as having
to create
a quantum mechanical simulation that's
large enough to capture the full human
experience like
it might be just as simple as just a
really nice quake
game like with a nice engine with you
know
that just creating all the basic visual
elements that tricked
our cognitive our visual cortex into
believing that we're
actually in the physical environment and
i think that
if that's true then that's quite you
know that a high fidelity digital world
is actually achievable within
you know a century and and that changes
things
yeah yeah maybe maybe in my in our
lifetime i'm really hoping for that i'm
hoping somebody can copy my brain waves
onto a virtual machine
yeah and uh you know allow those uh
allow that consciousness to continue to
exist
whether that's that's death or not i
don't i don't know
but i i think it's actually um gonna
require some serious leaps like even
even the vr headsets right
they um don't work if they go below 90
frame rates
right people people start getting
freaked out so you have to go from one
gaming screen of you know 60 frames per
second
to two screens of 90 frames per second
and so the people's hardware today
can't even handle that and that's for
these for these two little screens
by your eyeballs what it's going to take
to like you know completely trick my
consciousness
into not knowing the difference in terms
of like you know all the
sensory inputs um my i'm i'm keeping my
fingers crossed whoever whoever whoever
does that
and and is close to doing that they
should contact me i i want to have my
brain waves
turned into a virtual machine
you